dado que el ángulo a dv es congruente
con el ángulo abc ubicamos aquí en el
diagrama el ángulo de b que es este de
acá nos dicen que es congruente con el
ángulo a de c a b c este de acá y
también nos dicen que el ángulo beade
ve a de este ángulo de acá lo marco
diferente porque no es el mismo que los
de aquí abajo este ángulo verde es
congruente con el ángulo sea de c&a de
estos dos son iguales y tienen las
mismas marcas demuestre que el triángulo
ve a de ese triángulo verde que es el
triángulo de la izquierda es congruente
con el triángulo se ve que es este
triángulo de aquí de la derecha y aquí
nos dan que el ángulo b a b es
congruente con c de este ángulo de acá
es congruente con este otro eso ya nos
lo habían dicho y nos dicen también que
el ángulo a debe es congruente con el
ángulo abc esto ya los habíamos marcado
como probamos esto una cosa que sabemos
y que casi casi es obviamente intuitiva
es que la medida de ese segmento es
igual a sí misma y la razón por la que
esto es algo útil de expresar es porque
este lado este segmento este segmento
ave es parte de ambos triángulos vamos a
marcar nuestro aquí y este es igual a sí
misma vamos a escribirlo acá
útil porque es un lado que está en los
triángulos escribimos ave es congruente
con d
por la propiedad reflexiva que es la
propiedad más obvia que puede haber que
algo es igual a sí misma aquí esta
propiedad reflexiva y ahora como ya
hemos puesto suficiente información
ahora sí podemos decir que el triángulo
izquierdo es congruente con el derecho y
la razón por la que lo podemos decir es
que tienen un ángulo correspondiente un
lado correspondiente y otro ángulo
correspondiente
este ángulo este lado y este otro ángulo
y hablamos en otros vídeos del por qué
esto de ángulo lado ángulo funciona para
esta afirmación ya que si tenemos dos
triángulos que tienen congruentes un
ángulo un lado y otro ángulo va a ser
imposible que yo pueda dibujar los o
todos los lados del triángulo que sean
diferentes entre sí entre estos dos
trenes por eso con esto es suficiente
para decir que es congruente este
triángulo con este otro el triángulo
beade y quiero asegurarme que tengo los
lados correspondientes bien lo que
corresponde con el vértice b de este
triángulo corresponde con el vértice del
otro entonces voy a escribir primero
aquí se luego queremos pasar de a a b y
las razones por tenemos ángulo al lado
ángulo no buscamos aquí en ángulo lado
ángulo l a él creo que con eso
terminamos vamos a checar nuestra
respuesta damos clic y carita feliz muy
bien